vous savez que l'amour m'a emmené dans
des endroits assez sombres, mais Los Angeles
doit être aussi sombre que cela permet à vos
abonnés de voir une image et d'imaginer que
vous êtes au sommet du monde, ce qu'ils
ne voient pas, c'est l'effort que vous faites  mettre
dans ce fantasme que vous vous cachez derrière
cette façade mais pourquoi vous vous dites que
vous vivez hors de la terre mais que cette
respiration profonde n'est-ce pas que vous savourez le
muffin sans gluten vous lissez votre
ego et rompez un jeûne intermittent
si c'était en fait  une histoire de substance Je
pourrais vous pardonner d'avoir écrit un
scénario au lieu d'un livre mais vous n'écrivez
rien de révolutionnaire vous
vous dites que vous l'êtes mais vous ne
voyez pas que c'est le truc à propos de LA tout le monde
fait semblant d'être quelqu'un qu'il n'est pas
salut puis-je obtenir un nom pour la commande ouais
je vais
vous